welcome to this video play the rest mass
a giant giant from Spain he does not
have any information let's play
something else the Queen d4 line John
okay at least this was quickly played
okay Queen f5 the syntactic maybe I
don't know it age 494 why maybe this
this is possible 94 the f 3g phone
or is it f4 f5 what I should do I don't
know okay let's play quickly md5 I have
a d5 for public i have e 5v5 i have not
f5 so those kind of breaks are not
really doing much yep you can always go
with B 5 okay so if i take i can also go
back to the tool or if i grab her sis
taking a g5 if it's this some this bad I
don't know maybe maybe this isn't a bad
idea preparing g5 and having 95 as a
possibility okay night is coming to see
five
okay don't know yeah okay fy5 is
probably still an idea night c5 Queen
f3b 492 should be okay f5 f6 is my idea
when he gets if he gets to see 5 with
this night at least f5 coming is not
giving up on the e5 square
yeah the only thing that worries me a
bit is the seat upon that might get
under fire okay try to push with g 6 a-4
i can just take before so that's not on
okay night a4 may be here when tending
Knight c3 yeah but I get g6 and them ok
b3 i will take once and play a three
okay I have to I have to fire him that's
a pure pure race situation
Bishop f6 ok
hmm
five is this 5 takes now it's probably
not so convincing oh there should be
three I guess not what I wanted to do
but
mm yeah this is my tech field slow it
feels slow somehow
mmm yeah what is my next move action now
is taking okay I don't mind that of
course
can I just need to play the most
aggressive moves at hope their work I
mean maybe he can take a five simply him
now maybe you can EF Knight takes bishop
jakes and what is my move maybe I can
take with the quia can tip with the
Queen it's not that bad now it's still
not easy for black Wow
Knight takes bishop 64 or what I don't
get it I have Knight f6 as well but I
can take d phi is Wow takes on g4 this
Bishop 996 check Bishop takes Queen B
seven Bishop f5 check King a1 look III
checkmate that's great ah so I cannot do
that but if I take with the bishop I
know then I don't have a discovery
because of the pin Wow okay so look
checks rook takes Bishop takes a five
and then yeah moving the King looks can
take a three at least
Wow rather that's not good here okay
this will probably lose but so will
check takes Queen takes why is this
winning and high margin I don't see why
this wins check I rook a true not be to
hook a tow I overlooked rook a2 ah ok
yeah but it's nice elf checkmate that
was nice and probably does this mean I'm
lost probably it does mean that right
Knight f6 wins no it doesn't like when
Sam Wow yeah I around here yeah okay
white is totally winning but I didn't
see how I can just take g6 ah how
idiotic is that I can just take g6 Anton
resigns oh wow I completely overlooked
the whole thing my dad's very trivial
even yeah I just need to to get this
away and no Knight f6 wins easily okay I
had the hunch that this was not working
but I simply forgot about the move or
whatever I had a blackout yet him he's
all of a sudden very much in good shape
yeah Knight takes e4 is just crazy yeah
yeah yeah I should trust your instincts
I was really thinking okay this is this
must be nonsense but I didn't see why
takes on g6 this is just refuting it
threatening this threatening this
threatening everything and twins
ok Jim yeah here I'm probably really
lost their other threats are too much
yeah i was what i was thinking here
actually i saw that this is not working
but he has routed to me that's very cute
ok thanks for watching